what's going on guys this is rob and i
wanted to test the waters here a little
bit with the most recent release of the
doctor strange trailer and i want to
focus on the origin here of america
chavez the only reason why i'm doing
this is because you know i want to kind
of see if anybody's interested in this
before i devote all the time and energy
to making like a full-on character
explanation because she is very
extensive despite the fact that she's
only been around for about 10 years or
so so here's the thing about america
chavez she originally appeared back in
2011 in a story that was called
vengeance but the reality is that her
appearance here was one limited to the
idea that she was part of a team called
the teen brigade which basically
operated like kind of underground there
was sort of a black ops team to a degree
you didn't get much in the way of her
origin all you really knew is that she
had basically been adopted by a family
called the satanas and then through a
combination of arguments and the fact
that she basically needed to keep a low
profile she wanted to be a hero for
reasons that we didn't necessarily fully
understand that she ultimately abandoned
them and then took the surname of chavez
right and then just kind of went forward
as america chavez the first real origin
for her character actually came in
kieran gillen's young avengers back in
2013 and 2014 and it came through a
couple of different versions the first
one was an issue number three and the
second was an issue number 14. i guess
it's really kind of the same origin uh
but basically being told from two
different perspectives so the way it was
told is that america chavez initially
came from a place that was called the
utopian parallel and the idea behind
this and kieran gillan never fully
fleshed this out the utopian parallel
was basically a place that was developed
by the demiurge now the demiurge in
marvel comics exists in a couple
different forms there is the old roy
thomas demi urge which was basically a
way to explain the existence of like
life on earth the elder gods all that
kind of stuff that the earth's biosphere
actually is sentient and it's called the
demiurge and basically is the reason why
the elder gods existed in the first
place so like uh cathone and sidorak and
all those guys and of course as you may
know from the different videos that
we've done over the years eventually the
elder gods just sort of fell into
basically becoming degenerate and
started consuming destroying each other
basically you know fighting against what
was the early days of humanity or at
least conquering them and then
ultimately gaia essentially procreated
with the demiurge and then we got a tune
and then a tomb basically consumed the
elder gods who didn't escape right so
that's how it is that like catholic and
all those guys took off to other
realities those who didn't make it out
in time were basically consumed by a
tomb who in turn became the democ gorge
right so there's the demiurge and the
demogorgons in more recent years uh
billy kaplan the son of the scarlet
witch also known as wiccan has been
revealed to basically become the
demiurge at some point in time that's
one of those names that's kind of given
where basically he'll become like an
omnipotent person he'll be able to do
virtually anything he wants to and even
during young avengers he was getting to
that point where he could like survey
the multiverse and things along those
lines it was crazy how powerful he was
becoming uh kieran gillen never really
explained
which version of the demiurge was
responsible for creating the utopian
parallel he simply just said the
demiurge was the one who did it but
regardless of which version it is the
utopian parallel basically existed
outside of everything in the multiverse
which in and of itself was strange
because the only things outside of the
multiverse are the beyond verse and
basically the realm of oblivion which is
actually led to some fans believing that
america chavez is an aspect of the
multiversal cosmic entity oblivion again
that's not really confirmed there's
nothing to indicate that's the case it's
more of just a fan theory going on with
her character the important thing here
is that in this initial origin in young
avengers that america chavez basically
her moms uh were essentially the rulers
of a planet in the utopian parallel but
what had happened is that these kind of
black holes had basically opened up that
threatened to pull the utopian parallel
into the what they called the
conventional multiverse basically into
the rest of the multiverse itself
ultimately this was stopped but the
mothers of america chavez were destroyed
in the process and so realizing this was
the case and with her only being six
years old she basically escaped the
utopian parallel and then arrived on
earth and then essentially went forward
as america chavez well was adopted by
the satanism that whole series of events
and vengeance unfolded and then she
eventually became america chavez but
that was the kieran gillen explanation
of why it is that she can like fly she
can open portals to other realities
because literally existing outside the
multiverse means she could travel to
anywhere in the multiverse uh now
ultimately this origin was changed
really in more recent years in 2021 in a
way that basically pissed off all the
american chavez fans
and it's one of those things a lot of
america chavez fans more recently do not
like her origin as it exists now but it
is more comprehensive and it's more
grounded a lot of people are saying this
is the origin that we're getting because
of the marvel cinematic universe uh that
the marvel basically changed things up
because of that honestly the old origin
with kieran gillen would make more sense
given the nature of her character in the
mcu but the way this origin played out
is that all we had were basically the
mothers of america chavez amelia and
elena chavez and they were basically
just geniuses right microbiologists
pathologists and they were exceedingly
intelligent the problem with this is
that uh you basically had catalina and
then you had america who were actually
sisters and were suffering from
something called edges syndrome which
was basically a degenerative disease
that would effectively kill them now
technically speaking america was the
only one who had it catalina seemed to
have it but wasn't suffering from it
right wasn't experiencing like the side
effects and so the idea was that mr
gales this guy who was like some
billionaire essentially a mad scientist
would be able to examine catalina figure
out why edge's syndrome isn't killing
her and then basically take that
information and apply it to all these
other girls who were infected with
edge's syndrome and then were seemingly
dying as well now the idea of the
utopian parallel was invoked here the
difference is that unlike the old kieran
gillen days where the utopian parallel
was a place outside the multiverse
instead in the the i guess the facility
of mr gales the utopian parallel was
actually more of just a giant facility
right like a giant uh dome type place
where you literally had a door and time
passed differently inside this place as
it had been constructed by mr gales and
what that did is it basically allowed
the girls to essentially live longer so
that they could be studied for longer
periods of time in an effort to
basically cure them of edge's syndrome
the problem with this and and again
we're not given a whole lot here we're
only about four or five issues in to uh
to the current america chavez made in
america run so there'll probably be more
information coming about this later on
but for reasons that were never fully
disclosed it basically seemed like mr
gales had a kind of ulterior motive and
the reason why is because while the
girls were there to be treated once the
edges syndrome in america chavez started
going to remission then she developed
the ability to open portals to other
places and so what this meant was that
mr gales in the the presence of what
looked like government agents again we
weren't given a whole lot of information
there was basically encouraging her to
use her powers which pissed her moms off
the other concern about this is they
felt like the place was pretty seedy
right there was something going on there
that they weren't being previewed to and
there were some major ulterior motives
happening and so what happened is amelia
and elena had basically banded together
in order to not just free catalina and
america from the clutches of mr gales
but all the other girls as well now
ultimately all this came to a head
during the freeing process right when
they were getting all these girls out
when elena was able to get her hands on
america and catalina and amelia was able
to free the other girls the problem is
that amelia was basically caught on a
security camera and then ultimately
destroyed herself in order to destroy
the access door to the utopian parallel
and essentially the facility as a whole
elena herself was shot and killed in
front of not just america and catalina
but the other girls who were around
there as well and of course kind of you
know as a mother usually dies at least
as it was in the comics you know
basically said that she loved them and
that they need to escape that kind of a
thing right find a place for the girls
to stay and to basically become great
people you know that kind of thing the
way the way that the way those kind of
things usually happen when like a parent
and or mentor dies in the comics uh what
this basically led to was america chavez
basically opening a star portal that
allowed her to leave the island and as
she was grabbing catalina and leaving
ultimately catalina was yanked away by
mr gales which led to her believing that
catalina and mr gales and everybody else
on the island had been destroyed and she
went forward from there now the way this
worked insofar as the origin as it was
given by kieran gillen and the more
modern origin this was reconciled by
marvel in basically saying because of
her experience with like mr gales and
watching her mom die and all that kind
of stuff believing her sister was dead
that the whole origin of her coming from
a place called the utopian parallel that
existed outside of the multiverse was
basically just made up in her mind as a
child's method of coping with the
tragedy of what had actually happened in
the real world again pissed off all the
the the america chavez fans all five of
them they were mad as hell right they
were just absolutely angry uh but
nonetheless those are how her origins
currently exist in marvel comics so in
more recent years her powers have
basically kind of dropped off she
doesn't really seem to have the ability
to hop through the multiverse the same
way she did before that she's basically
just your standard run-of-the-mill
teleporter whether or not it stays that
way only time will tell i have to
imagine given what we're seeing in
doctor strange too she'll go back to
being the character that she's
historically been which is being able to
jump through the entirety of the
multiverse and literally it's one of one
of the things to know here she can go
anywhere in the multiverse or at least
historically has been able to she can go
to any reality sometimes she can get
lost but she kind of has this sort of
internal compass that always gives her a
true north so she always knows how to
get like quote unquote home so that's
one of the things that keeps her from
being being like irrevocably lost in the
multiverse the way that hank pym was
almost lost to the multiverse during uh
you know jonathan hickman's avengers and
new avengers but again that's basically
her origin as it exists in marvel comics
there's the original one by kieran
gillen then the most more recent one
that was released now in uh 2021
basically updated kind of reworking the
whole thing but with that being said
guys uh let me know down in the comments
and i'm pretty sure i already know the
answer to this but let me know in the
comments if you guys want me to make a
full-on like marvel comics or maybe call
it doctor strange to america chavez
explained video right give you guys like
the whole publication history of her
character let me know if you guys want
to see that thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace